welcome to this video let's play if for
against OT pop and let's play the Kings
gambit say someone requested me to play
the kings game but I have absolutely no
faith in this opening but maybe I can
shock this I am at least a bit ok is
playing the heart bear counter gambit
and the only thing I know it is not so
great but I don't really know why I
think it is connected with this move but
maybe some expert can learn can tell me
really but I thought this is right isn't
this right there should be three where g
three takes bishop f2 Queenie 7s quite
embarrassing ok and if I go g3 takes and
give it so you're keen e2 is not really
a move
but Bishop e3 is really normal and i'm
quite sure maybe a maybe yeah yeah what
else I may I cannot play kini to so
Knight f3 m27 I can take g3 this is not
a blood problem so here here i would
need to to second the rook Wow
huh so is taking Bishop to h3 maybe but
I can play Queenie to maybe 22 intending
a quick Knight c3 and long castle and
I'm frightening bishop moves not sure
how much a threat it is but let's say
Bishop h3 for instance is a quitter as a
? move because of Bishop g1 check and
takes oh not really yeah okay forget
that this was nonsense so maybe he can
actually play it okay played this one
Michael Bishop c5 he can play King the
age okay so night to d2 yeah probably
it's not the most active move but at
least it covers everything aha maybe
this check but okay I needed to cover
three no we're not not a big deal the
big question so what now I need to know
what I really need to do is make sure
that it doesn't cancel so Bishop move
move somewhere maybe just soda for it's
not bad it goes Bishop e7 I can castle
long yeah anyway here there's also g7
hanging as soon as it possible as a
possible news okay the castle I can cast
long now if he castles now intending to
give up e 74 f 3 f Bishop g4 a g2 first
now this is actually interesting oh I
thought this one and how does he protect
his seven at the end
not at all which means some it's very
good now but how to continue maybe
that's rookie to coming trying to play
d6 and go on b7
should I take don't really want to like
I can just play this one silly
you are complicated very very
complicated I take him Bishop f3
ok
now how to how to play hard to play this
position he's got all kinds of counter
play with the on the second ring yeah
this is silly f6 just f6 what the heck
am i doing I thought Quincy five would
be a would be interesting yeah just
nonsense okay anyway the game continues
so c6 is not good
now k this is a rather it's not not
badly coordinated the stuff everything's
covering each other and then i have d 6
and c6 and a blitz game that's quite
interesting now I'm not quite sure even
it is even maybe in a normal game so
probably not so bad b6 i FG six takes
Queen f7 end up winning just one idea
okay
no it takes Queen f7 and cons I think
don't see move Queen d7 Quimby some head
was dangerous suddenly I don't know yeah
probably very undeserved win but it was
suddenly dangerous hard to tell then
read but hoped know what this opening is
supposed to be but I think this is a
normal we should be three of them I mean
I think or is it just always at night f3
yeah well anyway this this was quite
interesting it's not Lots clear at all
if black is so great yeah yeah yeah very
unclear but now I can just take I mean
okay I first gave this the compounds to
take why will the computer also take in
seven interesting why is this better i
don't i don't know Abby should be too mm
okay yeah this offer this is yeah this
is indeed strong with AB in the bishop
it appears here and have a look at this
this is very nice everything's protected
now very well coordinated and you've got
this morn d6y a very strong what is
probably just winning even now okay but
I didn't I thought it would be better to
win this temple and then take yeah but
it is stronger I have the comp Wow Queen
h2 this is the computer move Queen age
too
in h2o man yeah of course we both didn't
see that I mean computer gifts this is
as better for white because I'm here but
a queen age too okay I only thought this
one and and now now why this is very
very good shape but it's it's not easy
at all to coordinate d6 is winning okay
because of 95 yeah I couldn't I couldn't
really calculate all this here he sees
certainly getting big counter play rook
h1 is winning out okay but it sits
computer chest you cannot see all that
Wow the computer has a plus for really
yeah okay I've got two pieces maybe I
was far too pessimistic oh this of
course was just a [ __ ] we should be
five completely nonsense Bishop Knight
be five is good okay but let's let's see
how it how it went down yeah yeah this
is given is unclear 000 but ok I know c6
and wide Windsor it's not defensible
anymore yeah I thought it was dangerous
but ok I didn't really appreciate that
I'm winning but I thought okay I've got
big counter play with until it's really
made 96 as a medium yeah this is so
strong and this is made them cannot
defend it yeah interesting game the
Kings gambit it's it it it hasn't has
some entertainment value
undoubtedly alright thanks for watching